what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion if you
need a cross into the box pray you have
an unholy money can't buy you silverware
is what the Chairman keeps telling me
don't hate me the doesn't view hate me
because I had a great world cup five
years ago and not much else I'm not the
new Granado I'm the first
vinícius oh except for vanity a senior
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you guys sorry Gareth availed but
thanks for taking the rest of us out now
you are just like your season tell a
legal tradition every night we all get
dinner at 11:00 p.m. and go to the club
till about 3:00 a.m. which makes us
perfectly ready for breakfast at noon
and then match it fun
Antoine do you want red or white do you
know little magician show you how it's
done guys excuse me um could you yeah
would you mind keeping it down please
I mean who sleeves that much what planet
is he from
come on Gareth for once have fun with us
slow down you know I have a problem with
conversational Spanish we are speaking
English to you we just have accents I
don't know why I haven't been able to
pretend I've even learned all the
Spanish I need I mean go ahead test me
okay call most us haste Oy
hurry doh que pasa
hey stoy herido okay sounds like what a
transfer well-read not cool man oh no
I'm sorry I it's just I need to be at my
best for tomorrow's big match big match
we are out of the Champions League and
the Copa del Rey and right now we only
played La Liga matches to get out of the
house once in a while oh no no my big
golf match I'm trying to beat my
personal best unless you want to join
anyone
alright well see you later
what's your socks we have a lot of
nicknames for Garrett like the Martian
because we don't like him the golfer
because we don't like him more like less
good Renaldo because we don't like him I
don't know something's off with him man
nobody in the right mind wouldn't want
to hang out with us maybe he wants a
train maybe he's faking an injury
I know let's go through his stuff to
find out what he's hiding because maybe
instead go to sleep and practice more so
we stop losing
guys I found something
why is dispenser so small I'm scared he
really is a now CI what's going on is it
is it tea time already get away from us
alien you're different and we hate you
but that's just my welsh books my golf
pencils and my exfoliating mask please
off of all oh now you speak Spanish I
tried to fit in but after six years it's
clear I am the only true galactica here
I don't belong at Real Madrid it's time
for me to go home
[Music]
[Music]
I will stick with red thank you guys all
right sorry Harry it's actually the line
is subscribed to this channel Prague
subscribe to this channel sure ok come
on
subscribe subscribe yes yes keep going
yeah yeah whatever that's fine